háháhá
foto pessoal de quem fala nada que seja
muito bem vindo à era mais um carioca
sua luta no chão pois você só quer a
instituição então posso nós vamos ter de
destruição mais uma vez mas não quando
vier o bom dia para ele parte mesma
coisa contra uma lua nova que é lula tá
agora comparem todo cinema jogo tudo é
que esse pessoal é luva do tipo a nós só
não comprei que o brinquedo a nova lua
do tennessee e por quem não conhece peça
então já que o personagem lado os
vendedores sabem que um novo tempo e não
sei se vocês viram eu ainda não viu sob
esse nosso caso que tá mas já virei
simultâneos portanto eu comprei que amam
deus olha só o poder que estão a entrar
no universo não se estuda as formas mas
já toda a gente sabe isto é preocupante
só com essa luva softwares suco consegue
destruir 50 por cento da população
mundial do mundo e como é que consegue
se com todas estas gemas
carol estava incumbida de ontem tudo o
brinquedo que o clube nunca temp lista
que já vem é porque eu não sou rodrigo
quando fizerem um brinquedo meu me
tomava ilhas com o texto o assessor
então eu só colocar o pneu mas só vou
experimentar e vou tentar destruir
coisas com a luva detalhes muitas
crianças porque o fisco goodluck vocês
gostaram muito e pediram mais importante
é que está nos preocupando só lutou
muito e depois dos comentários parece
que não me sinto muito tempo portanto
tuberculose é não pedir mais muito de
você inclusive planejou explorar jogos
de rua em breve vou estar um tubo de
terror é um vídeo som e mexe eu preciso
de você só portanto fique atento ao
canal caiu vou lançar eu prometo se
correria dos pacientes mas foi lá só vou
estar aqui a atenção a canon já atua
sentir o plástico duro eu acho que vou
conseguir porque tudo com isso a anp a
fim de roubar está em nossas mãos e
extensão todos o estudo maluco da crença
hawn e já esquerda e outro olha só como
é que fica nem casa nem toda lá pô vou
começar amanhã começar aqui e eu pensava
que ele não estava lá dentro mas não há
pressa
o alemão só demonstraram que o brinquedo
eu por dentro tem se uma pega que só
vocês jogarem assim e não tem mesmo um
compartimento vocês podem colocar a mão
em questão é uma luva mesmo isso vai
dificultar as coisas para o meu objetivo
era quebrar objetos com esta luva com o
pisão de comando ultra e não vai dar
porque não consigo ficar aqui vão mais
visitar eu vou tentar ser lançada assim
relata de qualquer coisa com isso para
lá então só vamos destruir coisas que já
sabem deixei muito aqui neste vídeo se
quiserem office quiserem e foi nós aqui
no canal só eu sou daqui e inscrevam se
vai haver muita destruição agora daqui
para frente portanto acompanhe e vamos
fazer tricô
a primeira coisa que eu tenho aqui ó
é isso o um grande olhar pra dizer muito
grande e muito duro porque eu acho que
vai acontecer é quando o jogo é que vai
curtir luva mexe é o carro se eu podia
deixar o supremo do universo então
quando está sol
três do vôo o futebol que o plástico eo
nude dentro tudo mundo achar outra deve
fazer edital
[Música]
gay brasil numa tarde muito poderosa mas
sua força apenas um ainda podem usar as
outras forças que eu nem sei de nada têm
que ver o filme
ok vamos tentar agora porque ele está
aqui agora
agora a chuva só lugar e focar agora
tudo isso fez assim o plantio onde isso
porque o luva de juntar émeraude
charlotte kalla
[Música]
eu sou do ebó final para tratar a cabeça
bola o próximo objeto que vai ser a
nossa amiga conar com certeza nossa lap
top copa não vai desistir é pouco de
jogo é mais duro e ainda tenho aqui o
tupi em juiz eu acho complicado enduro
só cometem a nós vocês acham que luva do
país vai assistir assim intacta até o
fim do vídeo se vocês acham que ela vai
ficar toda a partida toda destruída
comenta aí podem limitar nos a mesma do
cometa
o que vocês acham só o jogo também é de
já não se encontra 100 mas eu só como
ficou o poderoso sujo tudo ou ex
brothers grimm e por incrível que pareça
eu torço pra que o bonexo já é eu
prometo não fazer o jogo em cima tá tudo
sujo oi
é isso que eu podia do carro
no entanto é próximo verão a sua hora
vai ser um desvão do espanhol está
pedindo ajuda a quebrar tudo eo edifício
tempo nela ainda eu vou destruir você
foi tão bom o bulls a turma de aveiro ua
entrou assim realmente o mundo podem
adquirir
[Música]
assinamos a disciplina para isso
esse interesse financeiro com um terá
sim eu sei mais curioso é que cada um
olha só o próximo objetivo que nós vamos
destruir nossa lua do que a nossa vai
ser uma via que vocês não têm vido que
vocês plantaram muito daqui e sete
policiais agentes a comida não há muita
gente que merece comida e eu não comi
não veio comigo e depois do vídeo no
começo como um assediador eu vou
destruir o jogo melhor e logo não
estamos contra 11 a 3
a chapa foi isto olha só eu vou usar as
mãos mas não para mim
havia pessoas nunca se pôde só eu
quebrei banho maio e começo já falei
isso é possível se não fosse por causa -
não use do amor é é a nossa lua
conseguiu assistir tudo olha está
perfeita está a funcionar
agora só falta um único teste que é
tentar usar essa luva contra um ser
humano ou alguma figura de que só vai
ser muito maior já que eles viriam a se
concentrar em uma retomada vai deixar
ninguém
aos 21
[Música]